alors en fait ils te demandent juste une
adresse mail
ok t'as pas de mail il me faut un mot de
passe un truc facile à retenir
1664 ah bah c'est bien ça comme la bière
c'est mon code de carte bleue ah bah non
c'est pas bien du tout ça donne moi
d'autres chiffres avec des lettres x-37b
5,8 r2 ok parfait bh3 hockey confirmé le
mot de passe oui vas-y prédit le enfin
comment veux tu que je me souvienne de
tous ces chiffres et toutes ses lettres
jacqueline doucement moins vite
jacqueline comme ton prénom status
electro et tout de suite que je suis
débile
non j'ai pas dit ça @ comme ça gmail
de quoi belle non mais moi j'ai rien
gmail gm haï el points comme un point
commun points voilà qu'on a pointé avec
un thé donc il faut un point point mais
non maman tu as écrit points non juste
un point comme ça
comme com com normalement tu fais exprès
mais pas du tout tu dis comme comme quoi
et comme rien comme ses eaux m
je ne comprends rien alors moi
l'internet c'est la dernière fois